bonsoir jérôme blanchet gravel merci
d'être avec nous donc la langue de
molière qui serait en déclin au canada à
montréal notamment au québec
pourquoi pour quelle raison est ce qu'on
se l'expliquent
je voudrais que c'est un débat qui
revient être assez régulièrement dans la
vie politique du québec quand c'est le
français c'est vraiment considéré comme
le coeur même de l'identité québécoise
donc évidemment c'est l'idée que la
survie du québec même passe par la
survie du français
donc évidemment vous connaissez les
géographies du québec
donc on est environ 7 millions
francophones sur 350 millions
d'anglophones si vous comptez les états
unis le canada donc quand on parle du
village gaulois c'est pas nécessairement
injustifiée donc tous les chiffres le
montrent et c'est presque presque
consensuel la situation et surtout
problématique à montréal et il demande
dans la métropole où l'anglais avance de
plus en plus de parts de par la
géographie de par l'ambiance culturelle
et tout donc par exemple ce qui est
nouveau c'est effectivement ensemble ils
serviront une véritable volonté
politique du moins
oui embryonnaire mais quand même assez
assez fort qui qui s'exprime pour la
protection du français donc en fin de
pandémie
kobe 19 donc les forces nationalistes
sont optimistes elles sont optimistes
pourquoi parce qu'elles ont des moyens
de se défendre finalement oui on peut
dire ça parce que comme une sorte de
politiquement correct au tour du
français c'est à dire que tout le monde
tous les acteurs politiques au canada je
vous dirais s'entendent pour dire que le
français au québec c'est important a
donc ça fait partie c'est du discours
dont tout le monde dit oui c'est un
mental français mais ensuite
qu'est ce qu'on fait pour protéger le
français donc c'est ça la grande
question est là on sent que peut-être
que la loi 101 qui la charte de la
langue française donc si la principale
loi c'est la loi qui protège le français
au québec on sent que on souhaite en
fait là renforcés par ceux qui ont dit
qu'ils n'aient plus les plus suffisante
pour protéger de france est donc un
auteur avec s'appelle philippe lacroix
qui vient de publier un livre important
pourquoi la loi 101 est un échec donc
c'est un succès de librairie
donc les forces nationalistes ont réussi
si vous voulez à remettre à l'agenda
la question de la langue est peut-être
volonté de réussir finalement à ce qu'on
passe des actions concrètes pour
protéger le français parce que comme je
vous dis c'est bien vous dire que france
est important mais qu'est ce qu'on fait
pour le préserver c'est une autre
question la ccl on est dans le concret
et ça va passer justement par par kw à 7
cette fois ça va être comme en france ya
quelques années on n'aura pas le droit
de faire des anglicismes
là ça va être à l inverse c'est comme ça
que ça va se présenter
ouais c'est sûr que le dernier la force
des institutions mais c'est pas tout de
nos rapports des québécois eux-mêmes à
la langue
le problème sur le plan plus
sociologique c'est que le français est
plus précis l'anglais c'est à dire plus
prestigieux que le français est donc
dans les universités anglophones ne sont
sûrs financé par rapport aux universités
francophones le système de santé
anglophone au québec est aussi très
frais financiers d'un rapport à celui en
proportion va passer lui au système de
santé francophone donc c'est une
question aussi de liquider quoi au delà
de la loi et au delà effectivement des
ajustements sionnel qu'on peut faire
c'est aux québécois aussi de se
réapproprier une langue qui est une
langue internationale qui est une grande
langue qui la langue aussi de la france
qui est un pays banal dans le monde
donc même si vous voulez mon avis est
que oui
l'aspect juridique de tout ça est un
aspect sociologique il faut pas oublier
que c'est ce que c'est aux québécois
aussi au même de valoriser la langue
française au quotidien auprès de leurs
enfants extérieurs alors le projet de
loi de réforme la loi canadienne sur les
langues officielles finalement que
peut-on en attendre
d'abord il faut que ça se concrétise
pour vrai c'est pas c'est pas gagné
d'avancé malgré tout comme je vous dis à
tout le monde s'entend je le répète pour
dire oui en français cet avantage justin
trudeau a quand même un ennemi mais j'ai
toujours dit que le français est
important mais il ya quand même montré
des signes d'ouverture à l'extension
d'un loi 101 aux entreprises sous
juridiction fédérale ce qui est
important mais encore là ça reste un
parti libéral du canada
ils demandent des tensions entre les
forces nationalistes et les forces
souverainistes si bons qu'ils sont plus
marginalisés par les temps qui courent
mais qui sont quand même assez encore
présents donc tu quand même tout un jeu
de tension et de position c'est pas
est-ce que ça va se concrétiser on ne
sait pas non plus encore exactement et
elle est carrément gouvernement le goût
je voudrais que deux tendances août à
vence plus francophile une tendance plus
anglophile donc à l'intérieur même
vernement du québec il ya liant un
clivage
merci beaucoup en tout cas jérôme
blanchet grave est journaliste essayiste
de nous avoir aidé à y voir plus clair
sur cette situation